we're now going to start our discussion
of multiple linear regression which is
regression with more than one predictor
i should say the word
the term
regression is kind of unusual you might
be wondering why linear regression it's
a linear model
and this is actually it is an unusual
term it's it's actually historical it
comes from the idea of regression
towards the mean which is a concept
which which was uh discussed in the
early 1900s now you might want to look
that up yourself and uh later on in the
course we'll describe what what the
regression towards the mean is but it's
it's resulted in a sort of unusual name
for for for a linear model called
um
linear regression but
we have to live with this term because
it's become sort of time-honored
so multiple linear regression now
extends the simple model till we have
more than one predictor like in this our
example we have three predictors right
so we want to fit them all together and
use them all together to predict the
outcome
so here's the model
we have a an overall
intercept term and then we have a slope
for each of the predictors in the model
which again the the betas are the
parameters they're unknown
and the x's are observed and we're
trying to use the x's to predict why
so in the advertising example to be
particular we'll have the three
predictors
tv radio and newspaper advertising and
we're going to try to predict sales
and we have the error term for
allowing points to deviate around
the function and now the function
actually is a it's a called a hyperplane
let's actually flip ahead to slide
19 for a moment i have a picture of this
so whereas before we had a
line
now it's a hyperplane
okay so i've been able to draw it here
just for two predictors
um
it's hard to draw for three but now with
the lines is now replaced by this flat
surface called a plane or hyperplane
okay
so here's our data points for each point
we have its two predictor values
let's say tv and newspaper and we have
its sales on the vertical axis and we
and each here's each data point as a red
point
we're gonna what what multiple
aggression does it fits a hyperplane a
plane
to these points to minimize
the square distance between each point
and the closest point on the plane
right
very intuitive the same way we did it
with a line now the line becomes a plane
okay so let's now go back to the
okay so the model again so this is a
it's an equation of hyperplane with its
coefficients okay
well
before we talk about
the least squares estimates and some of
the details let's
sort of uh step back for a moment think
about how we might interpret the
regression coefficients because now
there's more than one of them and in a
simple model we had only one to deal
with now we have a multiple
say three coefficients
how do we interpret them
together well
if the predictors had no correlation
now it's in the data
then we could talk about each each
predict each coefficient separately
we could we can make statements like a
unit change in xj for example
is associated with the beta j change
that's this coefficient in the outcome
with all the other
other variables fixed
but
um predictors are not usually
uncorrelated in the in the data for
example here
we can expect and we'll see that
actually that the the
various amounts spent on the three kinds
of advertising are quite are correlated
so
these kind of interpretations are
difficult
in in in these in an observational data
where they're correlated
what is what what problem does the
correlation cause
well the variance of all coefficients
tend to increase sometimes dramatically
in particular imagine we have two
predictors which are which are almost
identical
right
then we can't really separate their
coefficients right
if i have a coefficient on one variable
i could just as soon move that
coefficient to the other variable
and the fit of the model is going to be
pretty much the same
so the variance of the coefficients of
those two
predictors are going to be very very
large right
um and then interpretation becomes
difficult when there's correlation
because
if one can't really say suppose i were
to change xj and i was if we can think
about suppose i was to change i was to
increase the tv advertising by a certain
amount
will be the effect on sales
well
if that happened we might as we probably
wouldn't be reasonable to assume that
the other advertising budgets stay the
same
for example maybe the company has a
fixed budget overall so that if i
increase tv advertising i would have to
decrease the other advertising
or maybe tv advertising is increasing
just because the company has more money
in general
and
and decides it wants to spend more on
advertising of all kinds
so this
in both those cases we can't we don't
really can't really talk about
the change of one predictor where the
other one's fixed because
the the predictors will tend to move
together in the in real data
and what this means is claims of
causality should be avoided right we
can't really say that
one predictor causes the outcome when
there's when there's predictors
in the system that are correlated with
that given predictor
so this becomes a
complicated
um
challenge to try to discuss causality
and we're going to avoid that
and
there's a nice book which actually i was
when i was a graduate student i was one
of the books i i learned from data
analysis and regression by most element
two very famous statisticians
um
and
i look at the book now and i don't
really
i don't like the book that much overall
but there's one wonderful chapter on uh
called the woes of regression
coefficients that talks about
uh
the problems of interpreting regression
coefficients when there's in a multiple
regression model that's a very useful
chapter to read
and i've made this point so the first
point here i've just made that
the regression coefficient
what it measures is the change in y per
unit change in xj with all other
predictors held fixed
but this is not usually a reflection of
reality because usually when you change
one predictor the others change as well
i mentioned the example with advertising
so here's here's
a couple of examples which i'll have to
have you think about
um
and maybe we'll put on a quiz but here's
an example
the first example to have you think
about this point
suppose i measure the total amount of
change in your pocket
um
and that's why but i also measure two
predictors the number of coins
and the number of pennies nickels and
dimes that's x2
now by itself the regression coefficient
of y on the total number of pennies
nickels and dimes will probably be
positive right the more you have of
these the more likely that you
have more change
but what about if i have
x1 in the model
right so for a given level of x1
um
think about whether the coefficient of
x2 will be positive or negative
okay
and
we'll talk we'll talk about the answer
to this later on but that's it's a
simple example where you can see now how
the effect how how the presence of one
predictor affects the way that we think
about interpret the coefficient of
another predictor and of course these
two predictors are highly correlated by
construction
another example which is actually from
this book this chapter in this book
um from from american football
why is the the um
the number of tackles by a football
player in the season
uh w and hr's height and weight
and
they they imagine that they take data on
from this situation they fit a
regression model
and they obtain
you know
beta0 but but the coefficient of weight
is 0.50
coefficient of height is minus 0.10
which seems to say that it's better to
be short
to make more tackles but
so the question we're asking here is how
would you interpret this coefficient of
height
given the weights in the model
and again think about this and we'll
return to the answer later
and
they out they also mention
in that same book
there's two quotes
essentially by george box who is another
famous statistician
essentially all models are wrong but
some are useful
so this is uh
it's interesting because it's true that
as we saw like on the very first slide
the regression model
a linear model is never exactly right
but some but it's often very useful so
it's it's important to remember that
the model that you assume is you know
not not to take it too seriously test
out your model
remember that's going to be wrong
but
but
also remember the fact that despite the
fact it can be
it's an approximation it can be it can
be very useful approximation in many
situations
and then this point
in their chapter also paraphrasing
george box
which really uh sort of it sums up the
what i talked about trying to interpret
regression coefficients the only way to
find out what will happen when a complex
system is disturbed is to disturb the
system
not merely to observe it passively in
other words if you want you want to make
a causal
statement about a predictor for an
outcome
you actually have to be able to take the
system and perturb that that particular
predictor
keeping the other ones fixed
that will allow you to make a causal
statement about
a variable like xj and its effect on the
outcome it's not good enough simply to
observe
some some observations from the system
we can't use that data to conclude
causality so if you want to know what
happens when a complex system is
perturbed you have to
perturb it you can't simply observe it
so i think it's a very very wise thing
to remember
a wise summary of the of the the use of
models and observational data
okay
so how do we
find the least squares estimates for the
multiple regression model well it's
really very much the same the same
attack we took for the simple model
so our first of all our predicted our
predictions will be
given by this equation this is the
intercept
and now we remember we have one slope
parameter for each predictor we put hats
on there as we always will when we um
infer that value from data
the estimates and now the what's called
the multiple least squares estimates are
the values that minimize the
sum of square deviations
of points around the plane
remember that let's go
remember i had to show this picture
here's my
data points
here's my approximating least squares
plane and i'm going to choose the
orientation and height of this plane to
minimize the total square distance
between the red points
and their closest point on the
hyperplane
right those are called the least squares
estimates
i'm going to call the the multiple least
squares essence because there's multiple
predictors
okay there's actually there's there is a
formula for these coefficients for the
estimates it's it's kind of messy and
it's not something that one ever
computes by hand although probably in
the early 1960s people used to do these
poor guys used to actually compute least
squares estimates by hand
they were good at doing um matrix
computations but today we have the
luxury of fast computers
and you know in a program like r or any
other statistical package we can compute
the least squares estimates for very big
data sets very quickly so we don't need
to worry about the formula we just need
to know what we're doing which is we're
finding this the values of the
coefficients that minimize the
the sum of squares
so here's what we get for the
advertising data
the
the top table are the coefficients
standard errors etc so here's
here's the these are the least squares
estimates
again we there's a lot of terminology
here coefficient or parameter
we'll use those interchangeably and as
people do
the intercept again we're not typically
interested in the intercept because
that's just telling us whether the
setting the other three predictors to
zero whether the
sales is
the average
the average
sales value so we don't really care
about that but we care about the slopes
which are these guys
these three values here so we see for
example
the coefficient of tv is 0.046 standard
error the t statistic is the ratio
0.046 divided by 0.0014
and the
t statistic remember i said a t
t-statistic of a bigger than about two
is significant at 0.005
p-value 0.05 p-value so the p-value of
32 is huge and the p-value is
less than 0.0001
similarly for radio very big effect
newspaper newspaper looks like it's not
having much effect right it's t
statistic is minus 0.18
which has got a p-value which is
large
and p-value is close to 1. p-value is
above 0.05 or 0.1 are not significant
they're not they're not um
evidence against the null hypothesis
which is the coefficient of zero
so
but let's let's be more careful how we
interpret this remember each of these
statements is made conditional on the
other two being in the model so
in particular this this coefficient says
given i i have the
uh the amount of money spent on radio
and newspaper
spending money on tv is
still
produces a change in the in the in sales
so
in the presence of the other two
predictors
tv is important
similarly for radio the presence of tv
and radio
advertising
excuse me tv and newspaper advertising
radio advertising
can be effective but newspaper is not in
the presence of these two
so in particular on its own newspaper
may be significant it's coefficient may
be significant but in the presence of
the other two in the multiple model it's
not showing significance
and
we can look at the correlations actually
here here here the simple correlations
between the predictors
um
and we see there's some significant
correlations
for example
tv and sales
well
tv's sales is the outcome but
um
because in particular let's see radio
and newspaper have a correlation of
0.2 0.35
so what's likely happened here is that
any if any effective newspaper has been
soaked up by radio right because they're
correlated at 0.35
so
with the radio in the model newspaper is
no longer needed
it doesn't tell us anything more
it doesn't it doesn't improve the
prediction given we've measured the
radio advertising
and that's because of the correlation
being 0.35
on the other hand it looks like tv and
radio are pretty uncorrelated
and so the effects are
somewhat complementary
so that completes our discussion of this
example in the next segment we'll talk
about some important questions that
arise when you use regression for real
data analysis